[Music]
when we address human creativity I think
what we are dealing with right from the
start is what makes us human and there's
been a great short coming in the
humanities in explaining themselves in
order to improve the creative powers of
the humanities and by that I mean most
considerations of human behavior its
origin and its meaning within the
humanities stops about the time of the
origin of literacy when we can deal with
symbols and and with the first written
languages and understand them or perhaps
goes back to ten thousand years to the
beginnings of Neolithic civilization but
that's just an ID link of time in the
origin of the emotions and the set up of
the human brain that's permitted our
understanding the humanities and then
ultimately science to the bottoms of
their depth and this then brings us to
what I like to call an acronym papen P
AP e in and that is a designation of the
areas of science that are most relevant
to the humanities when they address the
origins especially of the human species
and the appearance of modern Homo
sapiens some several hundred thousand
years ago and happened pa pe n stands
for paleontology anthropology psychology
evolutionary biology and in neural
biology these are the branches of
science that need information on the
origin of humans and the deep history of
pre human existence are needed to
explain the origins of creativity in
modern human being and the ways and the
reasons our emotions exist and rule us
leading to the way that I have tried to
put it in saying that modern humanity is
distinguished by Paleolithic emotions
and me evil institutions like banks and
religions and godlike technology we're a
mixed up and in many ways archaic still
archaic species in transition we are
what I like to call a chimera of
evolution we walk around and exist in
this fairly newly made civilization that
we created a compound of different
traits of different origins and
different degrees of forward evolution
[Music]